[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to the Googleplex.
This is an incredible place
with lots of great stuff being
worked on every single day.
Before I worked here,
I always wondered
what it would be like to
come to the Googleplex,
meet up with a Googler,
and have coffee with them
and just chat about what
they do, how they do it,
and why they do it.
And today we're going
to do exactly that.
Welcome to this episode of
"Coffee with a Googler".
Today, I'm speaking with MacDuff
from the Google Translate team.
And we're going
to be learning all
about some of the
cool things that are
available in Google Translate.
And it's one of my
favorite technologies,
because I'm a big
"Star Trek" fan,
and it's one of the
things that brings
like the universal
communicator from "Star Trek"
much closer to reality.
So welcome.
[LAUGHING]
MACDUFF HUGHES: Thanks,
Good to be here.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So welcome, MacDuff.
And tell us all about
machine translation.
What's it all about?
MACDUFF HUGHES: Well,
machine translation
is using computers
to solve problems
of understanding and
communication across languages.
It's based on this technology
called statistical machine
translation, because
most of how it works
is based on finding very
large numbers of examples
of translations, mostly
on the World Wide Web,
and using statistics to
see how various words
and groups of words and phrases
tend to be translated from one
language to another so that
it can make reasonable guesses
about how to translate
a sentence it's never
seen before.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I see.
So it's not a straight, like,
look-up table of this word
is this, this word is this.
MACDUFF HUGHES: No.
No.
It has a lot of statistics
about possible translations
and some pretty advanced
algorithms to pick the best one
and how to combine them to
make something natural sounding
in the resulting language.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
So sometimes a phrase
might be translated
one way in one document
and translated another way
in another document.
MACDUFF HUGHES: Yes.
For common phrases, we'll have
many candidate translations
for a language.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now, what kind
of volume do you get in this?
How big is Google Translate?
MACDUFF HUGHES:
Well, we translate
about a billion
characters a day,
about 100 million words or
so for around 100 million,
upwards of that, users per day.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
OK.
So, now, there's
a lot of languages
it must support to get
that kind of volume.
MACDUFF HUGHES: Well,
the volume doesn't really
come from a lot of languages.
A small number of languages
account for most of the volume.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I see.
Got it.
MACDUFF HUGHES: But we do
support a lot of languages.
We've worked very hard to make
sure we support even languages
with relatively low usage.
So we've made a big push
over the last few years
to get up to 90
languages supported.
LAURENCE MORONEY: 90, wow.
MACDUFF HUGHES: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So what are
the some of the less common
languages that are supported?
Do you have a favorite?
MACDUFF HUGHES: Do
I have a favorite?
Well, my personal
favorite is Welsh,
which I learned a little
bit a few years ago.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
[SPEAKING WELSH]
We're going to need translation
for that underneath.
MACDUFF HUGHES:
[SPEAKING WELSH] Yeah.
I started taking some courses
a couple years ago, learned it.
So we do support
that in Translate--
have for several years.
It doesn't get a tremendous
amount of traffic,
but one thing you learn
working on translation
is people are very proud
of their languages.
It's a very important
cultural thing
to see their language
represented on the internet,
to have tools
available to use it.
And especially for
minority languages,
languages that are
threatened, people
feel very strongly about them.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
Welsh is a great example.
I lived in Wales
for three years.
And the pride that
they take-- And it's
a beautiful language, too.
The pride they take in it.
So one of the things
as well that you do
is like an OCR translation,
so you can hold up a camera
and read text?
MACDUFF HUGHES: Yes.
This is something we
launched earlier this year,
was instant camera translation.
So you can just open Translate
and open your camera,
and point it at text, and
it translates it instantly
on the screen.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Right So for Welsh,
for road signs in Cardiff?
MACDUFF HUGHES: We
don't do Welsh yet.
We launched early this year
with support for English
to and from six languages--
French, Spanish,
Italian, German,
Russian, and Portuguese.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
MACDUFF HUGHES: But
just the other day, we
launched support for
downloadable packs
for an additional 20 languages.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, nice.
Nice.
Cool.
So I look forward to
having a play with that.
Now, one of the things
with machine translation
is that it's not
always accurate.
MACDUFF HUGHES: It is
not always accurate.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
I'm sure there's
some funny things that can go
wrong, lost in translation.
MACDUFF HUGHES: Yeah.
There are a lot of funny things.
Latin produces a lot
of hilarious examples,
because it's used in
funny ways on the web,
not the way people
normally talk.
People put Latin quotations
around in strange places.
Or there is this thing called
lorem ipsum text that printers
use to fill out webpages.
There was a conspiracy
theory going around round
the internet earlier this
year that there were coded
messages in our translations.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Hidden in lorem ipsum?
MACDUFF HUGHES: Yes.
Yes.
There were.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Any web developers,
you probably have
seen lorem ipsum
when you put a text block
on your pages, that's
the text that they auto-populate
so you can see layout.
MACDUFF HUGHES: Yes.
Yes.
Some of the more
straightforward funny examples
are when you get the
sense of a word wrong.
A lot of words in languages
have many possible meanings.
But one favorite that
we've seen is bed bugs.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
MACDUFF HUGHES: The word "bugs,"
in a number of languages,
it's gotten translated into
the word for software bugs.
So bug, software defects.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So there's a
software problem with my bed.
MACDUFF HUGHES: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
MACDUFF HUGHES: Or it
can get a little edgy
with "Are you free
today" if the word free
gets translated into
the word meaning
no cost, no price, no money.
You gotta be careful
who you say that to.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Absolutely.
You free?
No, no.
MACDUFF HUGHES: I'm
free today, yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: There's
one that I personally love.
And it was this girl on YouTube,
and she will take songs--
MACDUFF HUGHES: Oh, I
know where you're going.
Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right?
And she will translate the
song into one language,
and then into another, and
then into another, and then
into another, and come
in a roundabout way
through about 20 languages
back into English.
And then-- she's
a great singer--
and she will sing
the translation.
Have you seen it?
MACDUFF HUGHES: Those
things are hilarious.
Yeah.
I think they really
show how much is always
lost in translation.
It gets lost even faster
with machine translation.
But it's very interesting,
because so many things
are hard to express, especially
song lyrics and poetry.
Even professional
translators really
struggle to get those translated
into an understandable way.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
But what struck me
as remarkable was that
even though it was wrong,
that you got the gist of it.
MACDUFF HUGHES: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And it went
through all these languages.
And I think there was one
like "Bohemian Rhapsody."
And the opening line
of "Bohemian Rhapsody"
came out as, like, "Mother,
I shot a guy," or something
like that, after going through
20 different translations.
And it was really cool.
MACDUFF HUGHES: Well, that's
what's amazing about it,
is even though we do make
big mistakes in translation.
And a lot of times, you might
translate a webpage or a news
story.
Maybe not one
sentence is translated
absolutely perfectly.
But over the course of
a long enough document,
you can get a sense
of what it's about.
And the difference between
seeing a wall of something
you don't understand
at all and knowing
the general topic
of an article can
be a big difference to people.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
And that's one of the things
that the statistical base
translation helps you get right.
MACDUFF HUGHES: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
MACDUFF HUGHES: That's
the best thing for it,
is getting the gist
of an of an article.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
Now, one thing I'd also noticed
that you've been working on
recently is bringing people
who are expert speakers
of the language into the fold.
So giving people the
ability to feed back
into the statistical base
translation that says,
you know what?
In my language we don't
really say it like this.
We say it like this.
MACDUFF HUGHES: Yes.
So you're talking about
Translate Community.
So that's something we
introduced last year.
The great thing about
that is you said expert.
But you don't really even
have to be an expert.
Anyone who is reasonably
competent in two languages
and wants to improve
the translation
can go to Translate
Community and help.
This was something
that surprised us,
because people are just
volunteering to help
make our product better.
But I mentioned earlier
how passionate people
are about their languages,
and especially minority
languages or things that are
underrepresented in the world.
And for years, people
were saying either,
Google, why don't you
support my language?
Or, why aren't you better
at supporting my language?
And for years, we
had to say, well,
there's just not enough data
out on the web for us to train
our models on.
But eventually we just
tried asking people, hey,
will you come and help?
And there was a
lot of enthusiasm,
especially from these
minority language communities.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, cool.
That's kind of exciting, though.
It's like getting
people involved.
MACDUFF HUGHES: It
really is exciting.
We're trying to make it more
fun and engaging for people,
and let them use it as a way
to connect with each other,
and to feel some satisfaction
in what they're doing.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And it becomes
less about just pure machine
translation, and
people are getting
involved in the translation
as well, which is really neat.
Keeping the language alive.
MACDUFF HUGHES: Yeah.
So increasingly, for
very common queries
and casual and
conversational queries,
it becomes more and
more likely that when
you ask for a translation,
the translation
you see from Google
Translate will
have been provided by members of
the Translate Community, which
is very satisfying.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
Very cool.
So now, one of the things,
you've just recently
brought out a new app, right?
Or there was an
update to the app?
MACDUFF HUGHES: Yes, we did.
We just updated the mobile apps.
Like I mentioned, it
adds 20 new languages
to the instant camera mode.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, cool.
MACDUFF HUGHES: And we've
also made the speech
and conversation translation
much faster than it
was in the previous release.
So the big feature from
the previous release
was you could set
up a conversation,
and two people could speak,
and it would automatically
detect which language
people are speaking in,
and switch back and forth.
So that's happening
much faster now.
So you don't need as
fast a network for it
to work responsively.
We also improved
the accessibility
of the app for visually
impaired users.
So this launched just the other
day on Android and iOS space.
Very exciting.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I'll have
to download and have a play.
MACDUFF HUGHES: Please do.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now,
if I'm a developer,
and I want to start building
translation into my apps,
or using translation in my
apps, how do I get started?
MACDUFF HUGHES: We have
a Google Translate API.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
MACDUFF HUGHES: It's
on the cloud platform,
cloud.google.com And yes,
we charge by the character
for the translation.
And we support all 90 languages.
And we have a big developer
community developing
applications with that.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So if
I'm a cloud developer using
the cloud.google.com console,
the developers' console,
I'll see translator
there as an option?
MACDUFF HUGHES: Yes.
Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, cool.
So thank you so much, MacDuff.
That was really awesome.
And it's great to catch up and
learn about some of the things
and find somebody else who
speaks a few words of Welsh.
MACDUFF HUGHES: Great.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
thank you, everybody,
for watching this episode
of "Coffee with a Googler."
I hope you learned as
much as I did today.
It was, to me,
really interesting
to learn about the
great things that
are happening in Translate,
and the great things that
are happening when the
community gets involved.
And as MacDuff said, go on to
the Cloud Developers' Console,
and you'll be able to
get access to the APIs
if you want to build
translation into your own apps.
Or you could download
the new translation app
and play with some of the new
languages that we spoke about.
So again, thanks, everybody.
And be sure to tune to
the Google Developers'
Channel for more great videos.